Taiwan's coffee drinkers are more discriminating than ever,...
...and coffee shops are looking for new ways to win their loyalty,...
...including coming up with some innovative flavors.
Consumers are lined up to take advantage of this...
...coffee chain's "Buy one, get one free" promotion.
It's been so successful that the store ran out of regular milk...
...and had to use soy milk in its place.
I've never had soy milk in coffee before.
Today is the first time.
It has as an extra taste of soy, and I'm pretty surprised that I can accept it.
In fact, soy milk has been used in coffee for a long time,...
...but there are a number of other unusual coffee brews that are appearing on the market.
A few ginger slices, some ice and freshly brewed coffee,...
...all poured into a half a cup of Sprite.
Sprinkle a few ginger slivers for decoration and voila,...
...a spicy and fragrant ginger coffee.
After drinking it, your whole body heats up.
I'm already starting to sweat.
The coffee shop has also developed a red bean milk coffee...
...and a fruit coffee with strawberry jam and cocoa.
This trend toward more innovative flavors is likely to continue...
...as coffee shops try to appeal to more discriminating consumers.